stop man was that a stupid replacement
that's clearly a stunt man right is that
is that her face am i wrong
i i don't know look at their faces look
look oh my god look at their faces
look at those cg on faces
oh that is
when we first saw because we're sitting
like further back when we're watching
the show so we don't have as good a look
but first i was like that doesn't look
real yeah you slow this down wow that
really doesn't look real
[Music]
if you guys thought i wore this
daredevil beanie way too much well
it's not gonna stop if he's supposed to
be in spiderman no way home if this is
kingpin and hawkeye i'm gonna be wearing
this so much more now it's it's gonna be
my new hair it's gonna be permanently
attached to my head guys new rock stars
we didn't catch the first two breakdowns
because uh that was thanksgiving weekend
but we're here now bringing this to you
late hawkeye one by three easter eggs
from breakdown from the man boss you
rock stars where's all my shirts yeah
i've got so many so many orders so much
on that cyber weeks i can't keep wearing
this one or the other
the two three all right let's do it
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of hawkeye
episode 3 echoes which beautifully
shifts perspective to echo maya lopez
now confirm to answer to a guy who
probably crushes heads and car doors
i haven't seen that in a minute guys
drink arrows to the clever camerawork to
the cryptic ways they make us say uncle
[Music]
there is so much to break down so let's
go back through this episode scene by
scene for everything you might have
missed the episode opens with young maya
lopez i assume age seven or so because
they're writing workbooks say grade two
darnell bisa who plays young maya looks
significantly younger than the other
kids in her class which both makes us
feel her intimidation while also hinting
she's intellectually advanced for her
age 2007 is five years before the origin
story flashback we saw for kate bishop
and even before tony stark became iron
man in 2008 2009. this episode casts
maya as a parallel character too kate
but with greater challenges in her
journey as a similarly groomed child
warrior and by starting her path
chronologically earlier it casts maya as
a kind of soldier kate could turn into
if she sticks to the path her mom's set
up for her but it also makes maya a
participant in a chapter of mcu history
well underway before tony stark came out
of that cave as we also saw with shang
chi's backstory with the ten rings man
that just made me realize that when it
comes to those videos that do like mcu
timeline chronological order of the
characters this show is gonna put a dent
in a lot of that oh yeah dude this girl
is actually way ahead of us she
completed her worksheet where she wrote
games to play our solitaire and i spy
since she's often alone and has advanced
observational skills also she wants to
learn how to play capoeira that's the
brazilian martial arts style showing
this girl's ambition and when we see
adult maya fighting later on it seems
like she's pretty well versed in it also
she writes she runs as fast as a dragon
and she even drew a pretty solid dragon
on the worksheet that puts adult kate
bishop's doodles to shame speaking of
dragons
advanced class as a larger dragon head
that eats the bird or hawk a shadow cast
by her father william lopez played by
the amazing character actor zhan mclaren
whom you might know from his great roles
in westworld and fargo so many other
things you'll notice framed on her wall
is a us karate semi-finalist achievement
award meaning maya's already fairly
accomplished at this young age and they
talk about dragons
um no
maybe they are
but dragons
live in a different world
that
would
make them
stronger so this way maya ends up seeing
herself as a unique being who must
toggle between two worlds you can also
draw a connection to the great protector
and dweller in darkness from
both of which are powerful beings who
have to toe the line between worlds i
mean we can't forget
iron fist
he encountered a dragon absolutely that
we never saw
in the show but it's still it's still
canon though and if that's vincent
d'onofrio that's kingpin then danny
randa's canon danny rand finn jones
cannon dragons assisted way before
shanghi then that's all i'm saying
that's all i'm saying now i still think
kingpin is gonna be the criminal element
this series is leaning toward but let's
also keep our eye on the den rings
operation which again was very active
during these pre-ironman years and they
did say the ten rings will continue on
as a disney plus series i believe i
believe that's what the case is or is
that a
heavy rumor
either way dragons could drag away danny
rand dragon
dragons maya asks her dad
i'm sorry
yeah it's implied that william might be
in some sudden financial trouble
connecting to his work with the
tracksuits and uncle it's just another
parallel to kate bishop his father
similarly faced some mysterious
financial hardship followed by his
departure and instead the girl being
groomed by a more nefarious mentor and
you'll notice william has a chest tattoo
of triangles arranged in a sun pattern
later on as an adult echo gets that same
pattern stitched into her leather jacket
wow
[Applause]
you did it again
with the lighting wow you really whoa
that is
you yo yo yo good you yo cause i noticed
both of those things and never connected
that tattoo that design on her jacket
then at the brooklyn karate academy one
kid gets thrown into the mat nothing in
the scene calls attention to this but
the credits of this episode are this kid
as little cozy meaning maya
second track suit exits the building
well obviously their boss is there so i
think this school might be a training
ground for young recruits of uncle's
organization you can actually see how
that second track is
leading the instructor of this class
outside almost as if to have a chat
maybe about which kids are showing
promise
it's terry silver masks maya's right
foot behind her backpack to make her
prosthetic foot more of a reveal than
this fisky moment uncle will take you
home after class
i'll see you tonight
[Music]
is gonna be revealed as wilson fisk
kingpin at least going by the fact that
kingpin is the boss of the tracksuits
and of maya lopez in the comics that the
show is based on also the show's
references to a head of organized crime
and the location of lot new york palace
hotel which in daredevil season 3 is the
same hotel that fisk buys also oh yeah
batman auto repair shop etc etc but in
this specific shot listen to the sound
mixing they give uncles footsteps
heavier thuds compared to williams steps
and he's wearing a tailored suit with
puff links which fisk in the netflix
series is famously yes yes
yeah if you watch law and order criminal
intent you know this is dinaprio's laugh
also something he every once in a while
admits in an interview did you finally
get something to eat
we wrapped
okay yes that breathy high-pitched
chuckle it just sounds to me like a
possible younger 2007 era wilson fisk
yeah there's no doubt it's supposed to
be it's it's god unless they're just
doing that to
mislead us yeah we didn't say it during
the reaction uh but in the comic uh the
matt fraser ronnetti is the head of the
tracks tomorrow he's very heavily
involved with the story he's not in it
throughout but he's an important part of
it and there were just so many signs
pointing towards it like yeah it just
seems like it would be kingpin yeah i
didn't even draw that i didn't even
forgot all about the hotel the hotel
yeah well yeah these are actual because
it's not mephisto again it's like little
threads it's like these are direct nods
to the character and they've also talked
about like i feel like it's the worst
kept secret of the shows is that they
want to get wilson fists back at some
point oh boy yeah and that laughed too
especially
so we got to adult maya alaqua cox now
in a boxing gym i did look for signs
whether this could be fog wells gym of
matt murdock but i don't know if this is
even in new york because there's like an
illinois state champion sign back there
but then she pulls up to batman auto
repair again assuming trust a bro moving
company is an in-joke with track suits
seems like a front that they might have
named in honor of their own big boy
kingpin boss it's not that he's even fat
it's kind of like bane fat like tom
hardy being fat he's actually super
super duper muscular he's fat buff
yeah but it's mainly muscle actually
he's really just a super stocky guy
that's even scarier there's a reason why
he could put up a fight because he is
insanely strong too so he's not just
some fat guy
[Laughter]
ronin slices his way through the
tracksuits a massacre shown in a long
take from the outside in just like his
slaughtering tokyo game though we must
ask is this truly clint or could clinton
actually inherited the ronin assassin
title suit and sword from a predecessor
who actually is this one here killing
william lopez a predecessor like jack
dukane and that could be why jack wanted
the ronin sword so badly at that auction
jacques du kane swordsman is clint's
past mentor in the comics and this
episode ends right before clint turns to
look at him we will see
but i could also see the series just
keeping clint as the killer maya's
father just keep that juicy tension
between them
some drama that's what i loved about the
way it ended because it could still
follow the comic origin of swordsman it
was in the circus eventually clint found
out he was like a bad guy and they had a
falling out swordsman eventually comes
back so that's like the real basic
version of it the way they they have
that at any moment they don't let the
camera linger there long enough to let
you know like clint knows
him or not but when clint does talk
about him in the car
with kate bishop in the limo and he's
like maybe it is jack maybe it isn't
when they're talking about the
butterscotch and all that stuff
there was nothing about the performance
that let on that he knows who jack is
yeah he wouldn't know right i think of
the comic his name's like joaquis or
something yeah yeah so i don't know what
the exact pronunciation is but maybe
it's the kind of thing where he changed
his name or something yeah that's why he
doesn't recognize him but that made that
cliffhanger at least this here made that
all the more palpable just here in the
moment yes but maya now finds her father
mortally wounded
[Music]
as in fly away from this whole world of
crime don't let the violence consume you
and he presses his bloody hand to her
cheek leaving a handprint face marking
just like echo bears in the comics this
show
rules
actually i just realized that going back
to your earlier theme of that
foreshadowing moment within you know the
actual shadows yeah hawking the dragon
and he calls her little dragon and it's
more foreshadows i'm not that familiar
with echoes i don't know if she's like
referred to as dragon in the comics or
well let me school you on that thing
then episode title logo unlike last
episode features neither of the two
arrows hitting the target in the a as
this episode is less about kate and
clint the archers and more about maya
now the location of the tracksuit
hideout is an abandoned kmb toys
warehouse which in real life went
bankrupt in 2009 and here in the post
spotlight we were working there
man
the dust another returning to the grown
man who's no play with toys you see the
track seats trust up bro moving trucks
parked out front which actually if you
think about it might be a good cover for
them always saying bro we're just
quoting our business nothing suspicious
but they also have this tagline smile
you're moving of course these girls
would tell people to smile hey
sweetheart i'm shoving their bed for him
down fire escaping singing the magic
dragons you should smile more
you talk
too much
blah blah blah blah
maybe i
rip out your throat now remember it was
night before now it is morning meaning
the tracksuits must have spent several
hours toying with clint and kate on
those riding machines that played jingle
bells of course reminding clint of the
christmas with his family that he is
missing i just remembered first season
of daredevil dealt with a lot of russian
bad guys
tracksuit origins actually i believe the
guy whose head was bashed in is a
russian guy uh oh
dude vendettas
and russians are also very common bad
guys in new york city and movies and
shows there are signs around this
warehouse for liquidation sale but one
behind clint reads nothing hell back
kind of an odd choice of words for
everything must go actually there's a
similar poster later that underlines
this with when it's gone it's gone just
sounds like a pretty bleak sales push
for toys during the blip apocalypse when
things are gone they're gone kate gives
tomas advice for the imagine dragons
concert again with the dragons this
episode and maya noticing clint's
hearing aid cuts his hands free so that
he can sign
oh uh yeah sorry
hard of hearing not deaf
i love that they don't caption maya's
asl when showing her from clint's
perspective similar to how they
captioned her teacher with words earlier
also maya cutting his hands free so that
he could sign is ultimately what enables
clint to escape because then qazi has to
rush to rebind his hands behind his back
which is where clint can use friction to
cut himself free without them seeing
clint claims that ronin is dead so who
got him that
yeah clint
natasha romanov and he is telling the
version of the truth here because he was
on his violent path as the ronin before
natasha found him and pulled him out of
that life effectively ending in the
ronin's murder spree after he breaks
free clint hides among the empty toy
stacks making this the second time after
loki episode 2 that mcu characters on
disney plus have hid from each other in
a disaster adjacent store setting it's
almost like these broken toys are being
re-shelved as merchandise to sell disney
plus subscriptions am i reading too much
into it clinton pins maya to the wall
with two arrows and then mid-jump he
slices an arrow past qazi's ear to sever
kate's tape notice how this arrow and
the other first few arrowheads are field
tips which are made for target practice
meaning that they're the least lethal
penetrating arrowhead just showing how
clint's objective here is to kill as few
people as possible all the stunts and
specificity of clint hitting the
tracksuits non-lethal zones like their
limbs their shoulders super impressive
especially clint's no look shot through
the guy's hand recalling his no look
strike on a chatari in the 2012 avengers
but i do have to give credit to the
background npc yeah yeah you get that
empty space outside kate wants to take
the red challenger which is a lot like
the car they drive
it's in the comics it's based on but
they subvert that instead with this
chrysler clint hot wires it come on
[Music]
yes more christmas music here the dance
of the sugar plum fairy which we hear
later in the episode
and then when they bump the car
the track changes to trip hack that's a
russian dance both of these songs from
the nutcracker composed by tchaikovsky
considered the most famous russian
composer this russian music scoring
their escape from
birdie directed this episode and they
feature this one minute unedited
rotating shot in the back seat of the
car which is a directional edited
alfonso coron's famous swivel shot
during the card chase and children of
men one of my favorite shots in the film
in that movie they accomplished it by
rigging a stunt car with a hole cut out
of the roof with a camera hanging from
the rigging above which they may have
also had to do here at one point you'll
notice the camera switches to handheld
as it moves out the backseat window to
follow kate outside the car and you can
see a lens flare from the sun which
might be where they concealed a cut and
we get to see all of them
great call putty arrow the next one's
less tricky it's really just a rpg if
you look closely in that car there is
just one guy in it the driver but yeah
kate bishop probably killed that dude
and actually fired him
on the windshield of that car right
until clint needs it at the end of the
scene wow i love the detail of that
action scene something as minor as that
he hits the challenger with the punch
arrow and then he goes and grabs it way
later on in the action scene and it's
going by so quick that it's such great
attention to detail the choreography and
the staging of the sequence oh yeah that
is so clever because in the moment it
feels completely random but then it's
like super useful when it comes time
yeah yeah it's great yeah it doesn't
feel like a chekhov's arrow or anything
like that and then this wire release
arrow that snares a bunch of christmas
trees to the truck you think of this in
terms of comedic heightening this is
totally home alone even with the
tchaikovsky music that john williams
totally ripped off for his score for
home alone and the bad guys are getting
all sticky first and then they get
covered with christmas decor there's a
reason we love this then clint fires a
pymtech arrow at a normal arrow that
kate brings down resizing it to be
gigantic it's about not destroying the
suspension bridge of course we call it
[ __ ] ant-man's teamwork and civil war
this arrowhead is stamped with the pym
logo so hank pym himself must have
engineered this and approved it it glows
blue the color of the pin resizing disks
when they are set to grow mode like many
of these goofy trick arrows it just
seems like all of pim tech contrasting
spark tech was really designed to be
less lethal in general and perhaps hank
pym is now the chief armorer of this
faction of the avengers look we all know
that the basic difference is stark tech
is nano attack and machinery and pym
tech is make it big or small
mess with it on a quantum level that's
pim tech clint gives her a usb arrow
which we saw a version of when clint
fired an arrow with a computer virus
that's where we've seen it
arrow it just bounces off ivan's chest i
mean even a usb tip with that momentum
probably should have impaled him a
little bit there's something about this
guy like when he broke the car window
glass with his bare fist i just think
this dude has been juicing on something
then kate and clint together leap off
the bridge and turn toward him stop man
was that a stupid place it was clearly a
stunt man right i thought it would have
watched it is that is that her face am i
wrong
no now look at their faces look look oh
my god look at their faces
look at those cg on faces
oh that is not what you do for sure
usually when we first saw because we're
sitting like further back when we're
watching the show so we don't have as
good a look but when first i was like
that doesn't look real yeah he slowed
this down wow that really doesn't look
real
but good try though it's in turn toward
us recreating hawkeye's big move that
kate witnessed from the battle of new
york in the opening frame from the
fraction aha comics but here she grabs
the bow and they do this in tandem
swinging down this time sharing the
power move as co-equal hawkeyes which
clint verbalizes in the subway car oh we
gotta walk the dog i'm quite sure how
long a dog comes by yourself one of the
world's greatest archers oh my god you
really think so i should walk your dog
they're cooped up all day yes they're
still not properly communicating and i
love the poster behind them for family
counseling framing these two as their
own kind of dysfunctional family unit
another rogers and musical billboard
appears tagline every avenger brought to
life which feels a little cruel both for
the dead of injured like natasha and
tony also for the ones who are still
alive like clint and then another
heartbreaking scene clint gets a call
from his son nathaniel to whom clint
says that he's gonna miss a christmas
movie marathon but that hopefully he'll
be there for ugly sweaters so thinking
about this every day that goes by clint
misses another pitch that one of his
kids said at that dinner scene in
episode one nate wanted to do
gingerbread houses miss that now he's
missing lila's pitch of a movie marathon
and yeah he's probably gonna miss
cooper's day uh ugly sweaters yeah even
more depressing when you consider that
clint spent five years of christmases
without his family i'm like ryan you're
great i watched those uh wha what is it
is that vanity fair
the thing that does like the the whole
career when they ask the actors yeah
when they do the retrospective i think
that's fantastic yeah and i saw the one
they did with a jeremy renner and and
the end of that he talked heavily about
like look the movies and everything is
cool but the thing i'm most proud of the
job i'm most proud of is being a father
that's like my that's his main thing it
really touched me in that moment when he
was saying that you could really see it
so i think it hit me on an even stronger
level because i had just listened to
that a few hours before watching this
that when i saw that scene it felt even
that much more authentic to me because
knowing of what jeremy renner speaks
about being a dad and then seeing it
here really strong yeah those scenes are
so lived in and i didn't even know he
actually had kids and so it makes yeah
it makes a lot of sense how those got to
be as resident as they are or maybe he
was just saying that for divorce custody
battle stuff
so i gotta make myself look good
yeah i gotta get that custody kazi tells
maya
[Music]
hmm so uncle didn't sanction their
hunting of ronin if it is kingpin it
would mean that he and the ronin have a
history and that he has specifically
spent these past couple years hiding
from the roman clinton kate wait in
chinatown decided to sign reading happy
new year 2020 something now there's a
set photo angle of this that showed it
was going to be 2025 that would have
placed hawkeye maybe in december 2024 or
since really the chinese new year would
be january 29 2025 maybe this sign is
old and it's december 2025. i don't know
i've been burned trying to pin down
timeline logic before in the mcu and now
with hawkeye there's some marvel
producers who said this was two years
after end game which would put it like
in christmas 2025 but i don't know if
that producer was really thinking about
it like that i just think that confusion
is why they cover up the year now in
this shot and the diner kate says my dad
was
fearless
and his whole life was about helping
people eh it wasn't clearly kate has
some hero worship for her dad who
probably wasn't that great of a guy
another parallel to maya whose dad was
also working for a criminal network now
the directors place the camera directly
between the characters that force the
actors to stare directly into the lens
makes us feel a little awkward
uncomfortable wes anderson likes to use
this a lot jonathan demi used in silence
the lamps between clarice and hannibal
just as a way to force the actors to
feel that discomfort as they are acting
across from a machine instead of a
person helps underscore the awkwardness
here clint feels awkward as kate probes
about the ronin and him being a role
model and kate feels awkward that clint
is stonewalling her we'd be fine with
those straight-on shots yeah that's
right
we're used to it we're doing it right
now it's
more awkward to face somebody and look
into their eyes
like we chat with a camera please kate
doodle's a costume redesign with the
huge h on the forehead like hawkeye's
look in the comics hawkeye scoffs but
his scar with a bandage on his forehead
does take the shape of an h kate brings
throws names for the dog using names of
famous pizza chains
clint talks about the tracksuit
organization they started small for
group there's the guy at the top he'll
do anything to grow the operation
i thought maya was the boss no there's
someone above maya someone you don't
want to mess with yes this confirms that
clint knows uncle and he goes on to say
go ahead and hit the supplier on the
other side and then hit track certified
management yeah uncle supplier might
have actually been that mexican cartel
that clint slaughtered that was
mentioned
if the tracksuits were after anything
else at that auction it's pretty
upsetting to think there might be stuff
in the avengers compound floating around
out there yes reminding us of that watch
that the tracksuits did make it their
priority to steal i did think for a
second that ivan might have been wearing
it because he was wearing a gold watch
it is hard to tell but obviously whoever
really wanted this watch maybe someone
who values fancy finery and cufflinks is
really going to be the key to unlocking
this mystery eleanor's penthouse we now
see has actually been reconstructed
almost exactly from its previous state
before it was all destroyed why rebuild
it why so attached to this property well
it might be because my uh great great
great great grandfather built the
building remember at derek's funeral we
saw a headstone for russell bishop
implying that this series is gonna
explore the bishop family history and
why they own this property for over a
century and why eleanor seems reluctant
to give it up kate brings up listings
from the bishop security database on her
mom's computer kazi works for a company
called sloan limited night doubt is
associated with any of the random people
names sloane from the marvel comics is
likely just a shell company eleanor put
on the books to allow her to fund the
tracksuits operations discreetly it also
says the company was founded in 2011
right before derek bishop's death just
another clue that eleanor might have had
something in the works before derek
mysteriously died off-screen remember in
episode one armand told her
[Music]
[Music]
implying that our mind believed
eleanor's success was actually due to an
association with someone probably uncle
willie also on this list is the name
kemp m which could refer to michael kemp
who in daredevil season three was a
riker's inmate from whom matt murdock
tried to get information about wilson
fisk's
extends the ronin sword right in front
of clint's neck from the right side of
the screen to the left across clint's
neck the same framing used to foreshadow
armon's death we think by this sword
during the auction episode one we cut to
black before clint turns making it still
up in the air if clint and jack might
have had a past relationship and that
sword might have indeed previously
belonged to jack before it belonged to
clint one last detail that might be
nothing but i want to point it out
anyway during the closing credits the
cast names are all designed to have
extending arrows from the letters most
actors have both an up and a down arrow
in their name except four actors who
only have down arrows jeremy brenner
tony dalton frothy and vera farmiga
perhaps a clue pointing to which
characters might not make it out of this
series alive clint jack cozzy elenor
hey you can support this channel by
checking out our kids
rockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow me
rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis and breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
that would suck if clint doesn't make it
out his whole goal is to get back to his
family his day before christmas
[Laughter]
oh no
happily ever after let him live on as a
mentor you know like i love the movie
breakdowns but for some reason the
journey of the show breakdowns i i
actually think i enjoy more all right
guys well thank you so much new
rockstars for putting this bad boy
together you guys kill it as always
subscribe to the real reject subscribe
to the new rockstars hit that like
button and hey let's do a paper
aniso liva if anyone could be the kate
bishop at our patreon page
it's gonna be you my dear 100
you got the personality
you got the attitude you got the looks i
would let you kick my ass and make some
fun quips any day of the week she would
oh she would dude and you would do it
with style you could do it falling off
of a bridge and just like oh hey john
looks like we won't be meeting at the
gas station after all then you nail me
with an arrow and a knot
it's got to live on for as long as
you're here it's never going to go away
and then you could wound me in some
non-lethal place and i'll have that to
remember you by for always and i mean
you've sent us a lot of really nice
stuff over the years but like nothing
lasts as long as a scar hope you have a
good holiday love you dear merry
christmas to you and your family and uh
you're one of the best presents we've
ever had in our life 100
it's double double meaning presents ce
and then presents ts
[Music]